[Musique]
dans ce cas d'espèce il arrive des mines
casimir que si tu arrives qu'est ce que
tu fais là smic mais je répète des mines
pour le joug des contraires le choc des
contraires
ah oui j'oubliais on doit jouer au jeu
des contraire aujourd'hui c'est ça tu as
oublié j'ai pas où j'avais la tête
j'avais complètement oublié
vous venez jouer avec nous bien les
enfants vous venez maintenant on va
jauger les contraire il y en a qui se
met sur le banc là une équipe sur le
banc et une autre équipe
assise dans l'herbe approchez-vous un
petit peu plus la parole
après tout un petit peu plus là encore
un petit peu voilà bon bon je vous
rappelle pas la règle du jeu hein
chaque équipe va faire un contraire et
l'autre doit trouver compris on commence
marquer allez venez venez à 2008
voilà bon alors qu'ils commencent tous
nos milieux
et là tu le fais devant devant l'équipe
adverse allez vas-y
[Musique]
bon tu fais le contraire tu attends tu
fais devant le voilà comme ça veut dire
alors vous avez trouvé ameno tu devrais
même équipe toi tu veux pas nuire un
vainqueur et vaincu c'est pas sa marque
se veut ça aurait pu être son effectif
non mais quand on est vainqueur comme on
est là et quand on est bien qu on est
triste c'était ça bon vous essayez si le
phare avec toews en fait un bond marie
josé marie josée vincent dias qui
commence voilà face aux nazis
tu le feras prévient joseph hayes temps
va pas trop loin revient vers nous voilà
ton dia face au oui
marie-josée elle contraire bonne idée ça
tu regardes un casimir nord-ouest tuant
fait rien tout à l'heure à la
alors qui a trouvé claude carole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
généreux c'est marie josée qui est
généreuse et vous a donné des bois tout
le monde est le contraire de généreux un
avantage et s'ingénie à eux et pas bon
et bien puisque du ainsi bien répondu
carole tu viens tu l'as en ferrain avec
laurence la relâche quand vous le faites
ensemble toutes les deux un s'est amusé
à deux lorrains étaient bien toujours
les autres là tu te dégage un petit peu
alors allez-y faites votre contraire
voilà alors que ce s'est passé
corinne et marie-josée un pardon
patiente
ces personnes disent que c'est carole un
bail ou pire petit petit
les grands noms mais je sais pas si tu
l'avais dit ouais je le dis quand ils me
je ve entendu quand il m'a trompée
j'avais pas attendu asseyez vous vous en
faites encore 1 1
corinne et marie-josée alors chacune des
plus grands et toujours et toujours face
aux autres voilà vas-y regarde bien que
les autres claude claude claude ottan
fait alain rayés encore un petit peu
c'est claude il est à paris marie josée
lord se trouvait à vienne dire un show
moins chaud pour corriger ça qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait là elle repassait son
linge et l'approché le faire pour
faciliter shoot se joue emma josé elle
avait froid c'était ça vous avez encore
un nom à l'horizon christophe christophe
et claude chacun son tour qui commence
christophe car c'est elle qui s'adresse
à l'est
rien et toi le contraire
bon qu'est ce que c'est chercher chez
vous un et après l'émission vous en
ferai autant alors bassin aveugle non je
crois pas que ces soirées des acteurs
non on aurait pu penser que c'était
aveugle vieillards et bébés
c'est ça aussi ça fait vieux vieux et
jeunes vieux jeunes lui faisait un bébé
pour bien jeune et lui un vieillard dont
vous à ses yeux casimir tu nous enfin
quoi moi c'est sûr mais librement s'il
craque
allez prends la place n'est pas au mieux
et vous le regardez bien à linge est là
ce moment voilà ça fait bien ça c'est le
numéro un est le contraire du numéro un
[Musique]
voilà et c'était le numéro deux alors
qu' à trouver et me retrouver vite
ensuite je vais pas soufflé un et abo
qu'est ce que tu faisais exactement
tu manges à quelque chose j'ai la
passion de koné qu'est ce que c'est je
mangeais dû par exemple du gloubiboulga
par exemple comme comme bazin comme par
hasard c'était à mon numéro 2 par
l'examen bien évidemment c'était des
laissiez bon trader
et puis en deux jeux en jazz par exemple
une chose affreuse comme de la langouste
où je sais pas avec sa dose d'amour très
très mauvaise
voilà voilà et bien c'est très bien
casimir